join the party go to
spectator.co.uk and get your first month
absolutely free rod looking back at uh
the spectator's greatest hits this year
on our website
it's fair to say a large number of them
uh have been about harry and megan there
seems to be an amazing amount of
interest in them
and particularly in pieces that are not
very favorable towards them including a
couple by you why is it that people seem
to uh dislike them quite so strongly
because they're vacant vacuous
privileged and hypocritical i think that
sums it up rather neatly
and partly because of course they've
done a lot of damage i mean they've done
a lot of damage to the royal family
which
a majority of people in this country
still have some respect for certainly
some respect for the queen and and the
sadly departed prince philip
um and they have done untold damage to
it uh
more even than harry's mom did to it uh
i suspect uh when we come to
tot up all these reckonings at the end
of the day um
but more than anything they are so
blatantly visible
sitting out there in a
californian mansion
with 18 lavatories
an untold number of which
have working b days
um
and lecturing the rest of us on the
need for equality
this kind of vacuous concept of equality
which is
always championed by
um
american left arenas and doesn't
actually mean equality at all
and
the other thing obviously which is the
most
common thing often said of them
is how desperately they desire their
privacy
and tell us this
through various conduits every day of
the week
and sign deals with companies such as
netflix presumably in order to protect
their privacy even more through having
fly on the wall documentaries and so on
they are hypocrites of the most
outstanding order and the term
champagne socialists could have been
invented for them well perhaps their
their desire for privacy might explain
uh what's going on with the spotify deal
that they did for
a large number of millions
uh and they have only produced one
episode in a year and uh i'm sure like
like me you regularly check your
spotify's feed to see if they've if
they've uploaded another one but so far
no
well they have a problem and so
obviously to the to the companies which
have employed them
and the problem is this
that
they are caught between a rock and a
hard place they have they have to for
the sake of their current brand reject
everything that the royal family stood
for
but without having the imprimature of
the royal family they amount to nothing
there it's just a gingerish hair head
and his pushy misses jabbering
unless that unless that connection to
the royal family is kept there is no
reason whatsoever why anyone should want
to watch them
well they've they seem to be trying to
create a very americanized version of
the royal family for the american
media market do you think although it
might drive brits like you and me
a bit crazy or make us cross
americans actually are quite receptive
to that kind of thing
well except it's nothing to do with the
royal family
uh
and celebrity dumb
and being a royal
are not similar
they're certainly not the same but
they're not even similar
they require different
qualities
celebrities
requires endless
self-publicity
and the endless emoting um on any one of
a number of given issues
being a member of the royal family
requires precisely the opposite of that
it requires
diligence
uh dignity
reserve
um and selflessness all of which are
antithetical to the concept of the
celebrity so
they can't get away with this and my
prediction is that they won't get away
with this for very long because they
will cease to be seen as anything
of any importance because that
connection with the royal family has
been broken but do you think it's partly
the royal family's fault for before
megan came along um i mean for decades
now the royal family has danced with the
world of celebrity and and
through the through the medium of the
tabloids it's it's flirted with pr and
and promotion and and publicity
it hasn't done so anywhere in the
anywhere in the league of what harry and
megan have gone up to
it is true that the queen has sometimes
been dragged screaming towards the pr
people
all of which began i think
recently with with uh with the advent of
tony blair
in downing street um
and perhaps they have gone down that
route too far
uh and of course harry and megan are the
royal family's only problems you know
there's the magnificent figure of andrew
lumbering around in the background as
well
so it's not been a good
year for the royal family and you might
argue it's not been a very good decade
for the royal family
and you do get the suspicion
that this whole thing is rather coming
apart at the scenes
well the suspicion seems to be that um
once the queen goes and uh she can't
live for much longer um
the uh
the things will fall apart quite quickly
because it's been the queen's reserve
and her unwillingness to
um engage in pr something prince charles
has engaged with a bit more that that
has kept the royal family the show on
the road
yeah i think that's exactly it and of
course the passing of the duke of
edinburgh was
was a terrible thing uh i mean a tragedy
obviously for the queen and for the duke
of edinburgh i suppose uh but a tragedy
also for the institution
of the royal family because the two of
them personified that selflessness
that dedication to duty which is meant
to come with being a modern royal
there are a few glimmerings of hope
uh in
[Music]
william and kate
who
are beginning to show that same sort of
decency and reserve i just wish they'd
stopped talking about mental illness
every 30 seconds
it is difficult to find anyone in public
life in great britain who doesn't
immediately tell you how depressed they
are and seeking treatment for it i don't
know what's happened to this country
but in the interim we have to put up
with charlie of course
how much better it would be if it were
anne
but instead it's charlie
and i dare say there will be one or two
problems there he is also given to
making
uh fatuous political statements
about which he knows nato as anna might
put it
so
we will just have to see it does seem i
mean
you look at the polls there is still
support for a monarchy but it decreases
and it decreases
uh gradually every year
and
you one one would expect that that will
continue to decrease
do you find i mean i imagine by instinct
uh i think i know by instinct you're not
a you're not a monarchist
and i don't think your politics make you
uh
inclined to support the monarchy but do
you find that the sheer ghastliness of
harry and megan um
makes you fonder of the queen and the
idea of the the older idea of the
monarchy
oh yeah well two things yes i mean
obviously
harry and megan make me feel more kindly
disposed towards almost everybody else
on the planet
by comparison
absolutely ghastly individuals um that
that that continual
whining
but the other thing which makes me more
kind of disposed towards a queen and our
current royal family and even prince
charles is a prospect
of what uttered dunderhead would be
elected president if we didn't have a
royal family and you can see it now
it would be some worthy
from the left
uh it
it's quite possible that it would be
um the famous actor david tennant or
or what's he called that sheen bloke
uh or eddie redmayne or baldrick from
blackadder you know
that's why
we have a queen so that we don't have to
put up with someone like that
well i think we'll end it there rod on
that cheery note happy christmas
[Music]
you